what's going on everybody welcome to the
seventh part of our super computer at a
raspberry PI's tutorial series in the
last video we made copies of our SD card
of our master nodes so now we've got a
second node that is an identical copy of
the first and now we need to do a few
more things so the next thing that we're
going to want to go ahead and do is log
into both PI's so first I'm going to log
into the master node which for me is 192
168 0 20 as we already know open that
one up here it is login as pi and my
password I think I mistyped it cool now
we have the second pi and again you can
either plug it in and login for sure and
then do ifconfig but you can also pretty
much go ahead and guess what this PI's
IP address is so my 192 168 0 and my
previous one was 20 so I'm just going to
say this is 21 and that should probably
work hit enter you might get this
potential security breach probably
because I've already done this you might
not actually get this I'm going to hit
yes that's fine because I've logged into
this IP address before and like via SSH
and now it's a different different
machine so anyway just just in case one
of you guys gets that as close to PI
again it's going to be the same password
as the first right even though this is
the first time we're using the second PI
we made a direct copy so that included
the user files and all that and this one
also has all the files that we just
worked on before and again you won't
have to do like the sudo make and then
make install and all that stuff that
took 4 years so now what do we do well
I'm gonna go ahead and adjust both of
these windows so they're fully sized so
let me go ahead and do that ok so I've
got them all set up good-sized window
and now again this is the master node as
you can see this is 168 20 so this is
the first pie you've ever used this is
your true master node hi now what we
need to do is we want to add
some RSA that allows us to quickly log
into all of our pies instead of having
to like eventually need to log in like
say you had 64 of these bad boys you
wouldn't want to have to always log into
every single one of them that would
really suck every time you had to turn
on or off or well every time you need to
turn on your supercomputer so the first
thing that we want to do is generate a
SSS SSH key so do SSH - qijin and then -
t - T stands for type so what type of
key are we looking for we're looking for
an RSA key and then - capital C which
denotes a comment so what kind of you
know note would we like to make about
this well this is our master node which
in our master node is really Raspberry
Pi at rasp Barry PI so this is our
master node and really it's mostly pi @
Raspberry Pi but anyway um so that's our
comment and what go ahead and do is
we'll hit enter wait for it
where would we like to save this key
we're just going to save it in in the
default directory that's fine and now
it's asking us if we want to pass phrase
you can put in a passphrase if you'd
like sometimes this causes trouble for
me down the road so I'm not even going
to enter one but feel free to enter one
if you would like I'm just going to
literally hit enter to not enter one
good and then here is your random art so
now everybody can hack me anyways
because there's my RS my artist Keith's
random art for everybody cool so next up
what we're going to do is we want to
share this with our our next pie so in
theory if you put a password it would
share the same password to use SSH
amongst each other but obviously we did
not use a password so what we can do
though is once you've done the above is
the next thing that we can enter here is
cat
that and then that the squiggly or the
squiggly means slash home slash PI again
squiggly and we want this to go in dot
SSH / ID underscore RS RS a dot pub I
don't even know bar SSH and then PI at
and this is where you enter the IP
address of your other Raspberry Pi so
192 168 0 and this one again this my
master node is 0.20 so that means my
second note as we confirmed at least for
myself when I logged in which is 21 just
one more so that's where what you'll
have to put in there so obviously yours
might not be 21 probably isn't then what
do we want to do well we want to go
ahead and make der dot SSH and then cat
I don't know forward arrow forward error
I don't know what you're supposed to
call this somebody knows what you call
this probably bar but I don't know what
these two forward arrows actually mean
anyway or do forward arrow space dot ssh
slash authorized keys okay
hit enter hopefully that works are you
sure you want to continue connecting so
it's kind of like when you connected the
ssh yes permanently added so now you
have to enter that the password to your
other pi which since you made a copy of
your master node is going to be the same
as your master node so enter that and
you should be all set so now what we've
done is actually created a file here on
the other PI so for example if we look
if we switch over to the other pi click
here and here so now this is my other pi
pi at 192 168 0 21 and we want to list
out even the hidden files of the
path SSH the enter you'll have some
stuff here originally this didn't even
exist so it would have thrown an error
before so if you're getting an error
something went wrong probably you have
maybe the wrong IP or something like
that but I think you have found that out
sooner so that's pretty much it
- tying your PI's together so you won't
have to log into every single one of
them so that's going to conclude the
sixth video now in the next video what
we're going to go ahead and do is set
everything up so we can actually
calculate pi using both of the PI's PI
on the PI and there's a few steps they
are doing it initially it's not too hard
but then we want to actually change some
of the names around all kinds of there's
fun stuff so anyways that's what you
have to look forward to the next video
is really your first example of building
a two node supercomputer so that is very
exciting so anyways
stay tuned for the next video as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until next
time